you know who showed up that i was kind
of surprised showed up
talent yeah yeah of all
people bc before christ
yeah he showed up
my second to last song
is when he showed up yeah yeah cause he
just walked in he was just filming me
like oh yeah
[Music]
have you heard that tick tock audio
where with nicki minaj's like cut his
[ __ ] mic since you want to be dumb
that's what i remember
i did i did track very much trying to
nicki minaj
jesus you look like nicki minaj
nicki minaj is a bad [ __ ] but to be
fair so is meatball i just wanted to say
that
it has nothing to do with anything we
are rolling yeah we are rolling oh [ __ ]
hey what's up guys what's going on
welcome back welcome back welcome back
welcome back welcome back welcome back
so what do you wait wait there's two
places you can know that from where do
you know it from uh well
i learned the first one second the the
second one is mace welcome back and i
knew he would [ __ ] know this and
first is welcome back at her
leave it up tonight wow
is that what you're going to say too
nope just the newer one oh you just know
it from me mace you don't know the tv
show nope i don't know why i said it
british you don't know the tv show i
know i said it bruce because i'm going
to london june second i'll be performing
in the uk are you so excited you're
going to also go see
a performance i feel like you can do a
lot of claps
and i'm going to see liam gallagher
perform the next night damn william
gallagher is going to come to my show
mm-hmm you're kidding what i'm kidding
but
i'm putting them on the guest list
why not you have for every show you've
ever put on but yeah yeah it's like
ricky bobby waiting for his dad
hoping liam shows up oh or austin powers
waiting for his dad at graduation he's
giving a speech
stand up wait what was the place they
went to in uh
was it applebee's yes yes applebee's
yeah shout out to applebee's i know you
do do two for 20. oh yeah right is that
your world i'll get down on some chili's
applebee's yeah oh yeah we talked about
this last time that's an ohio thing yeah
what's your favorite franchise out of
all of them
um robin
i mean if we're going to ohio we got to
go with the skyline chili if that's in
that category
what man [ __ ] that place
did i say that out loud that's all we
got there i said that out loud
you just like destroyed their pride and
joy yeah you know that right skyline
julie's not kyle told me it was joy it
can't be that's pretty much all we got
when you we're into ohio this is amazing
there's more to life there's more there
there's more life but it's really good
don't don't don't do you guys don't you
do yourselves like that
you know there's more to life are you
telling them to respect themselves a
little more a little bit more you don't
like skyline really what is it in
lacrosse what's it
uh like the franchise like a chain
culvers are oh yeah
i don't know if that's like the same
that's i guess that's no that's that's
fast food where you're talking like
cat cat elegant
elegant sit down i mean i like it nice
the skyline's fast food too
is it yeah well you could sit down but
it's still fast food do they call that
moderate fast cash fast cash that's what
chipotle is that actually yeah that's so
what that's always considered fast food
uh i i don't know what what separates
the two but uh
i don't know a value yeah
what do you guys got crab cakes we're
huge on seafood but we don't really have
like that many big chains like we have
applebee's chilies and uh cellos but
cellos yellows what's jello's place
called cellos what is it what kind of
spot it's like everything kind of it's
like it's basically another type of
applebee's
just like
or like the yard
uh the yard the yard house
yeah sorry
that's a whole different thing
the yard
we're talking about fast food you guys
just had your first show
we did yeah how was that yeah well my
second show oh yes yes yeah
your fourth show well like all together
yeah this was our first show in l.a
group setting yeah in l.a too this class
yes and then second lead where were you
last week
where was i
i'm like
inviting criticism i owned because i
didn't make it to the show last night uh
i was going to blame on jules but she
came with me today so i can't
why didn't you show up though she she
got like
up a little late and i was just like in
the zone editing and our episode was
going up the king and the sting oh and i
needed your help too because yeah i was
cutting clips and [ __ ] and i just
realized i didn't post the omni yeah
actually but oh [ __ ] you just realized
that right now as we're doing this yeah
yeah but um
yeah so i was just kind of grinding if i
would have left what time did the show
go tell me what's up like 11 40. i
already got up maybe a little bit for a
little bit before 11. i couldn't have
got there more than 9 30 so i was like
i'm gonna get there i'm gonna park it's
gonna be over and then i don't know yeah
my band goes like nine yeah they went
off like a little before 9 30. yeah i
actually got there at like 9 40 because
a similar situation happened with me i
had my tattoo session went home knocked
out woke up at eight got ready and then
left and got there at 9 40 ish you
didn't want to see my van i wanted to
meatball sent me a video so i did watch
you reach out yeah that's how long it
takes uh
you're in manhattan beach uh no i am in
newport so it takes about an hour and 15
with no traffic and we're like driving
hauling he's like super down south yeah
that's tough
damn that's a stretch it is it it's a
[ __ ] heist she made it nick
yeah nick
you know what it is though i just i
don't think i have it in me to
like not show up and then have chin say
the inevitable like thanks for coming
that my asian dad
he does it to everyone i can't take it
yeah i said genetically no i said to
jules though who i feel the worst about
is chin because like you so sincerely
like you're like you mean a lot to us
you guys came out yeah i said it means
the world to me he kept asking where we
were in the world
he was just sitting there with his
baseball mitt just like he was like
you know who showed up that i was kind
of surprised showed up
talent yeah of all
people bc before christ
pretty much everyone in this room was
there yeah except nick georgie was there
yeah he showed up i was there chili was
here
my second is the last song
right is when he showed up yeah yeah
because he just walked in and he was
just filming me like oh yeah
wait did he do one of these or did he do
like this like the
the dad oh yeah
like you're walking the stage at
graduation and your dad's just like
above his head
his final project is like a video over
himself he's squinting at it
and for some reason they always edit in
some like
obscur like song that shouldn't be there
like oh yeah like i'll be watching you
as if you died or something right and
it's just crossfades like yeah
in the video yeah when a dad learns how
to edit
so
though i mean some dads figure it out on
imovie but they do it in like the
corniest way it has the same energy as
those like macy's photo shoots from back
in the day has that it's like how does
that come up with that
that no one asked for those ugly new
balances not the good ones yeah
look how popular like
prevalent simple editing is now dad
edits in the next 15 years are going to
skyrocket skyrocket yeah just think
about it
uh
photo montages set to like 80s
that is such a dead thing no like when
they're very supportive of their
children yeah they'll start taking
photos and all of a sudden they think
they're photographers
they start filming and they start
editing and then they just make [ __ ]
that's what i do with butters it must be
nice
[Laughter]
tell us more nick are you okay
he looks fine my grandma's got thousands
of photos from me i i got my picture
taken are you a grandma's boy like big
time yeah makes perfect sense yeah
shout out to grandmas but yeah so where
were you
oh last week yeah but uh yeah is it i
mean i was just taking care of [ __ ] work
we're taking care of business
every day yeah
does tuesday work going forwards for
recording yeah yeah yeah that actually
does is that when you do chapelle show
no
i do it on wednesdays at 10 a.m
and they drop thursdays at 3 p.m
[Music]
you really [ __ ] with me don't you yeah i
need to stop talking [ __ ] to you yeah
yeah it'll change your dynamics
you know he used to be a football player
no yes i remember him oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait on the podcast
instagram yeah yeah did we we didn't on
fire oh cause he was telling me last
night i was like shut the [ __ ] up yeah
no that's like
he was a what middle linebacker middle
linebacker what does the middle line
you're making who's a famous middle
linebacker
mike singletary first one that came came
to mind um
and he's really good yeah he's elec it
bears legend and what do they do uh
they're like the quarterback of the
defense honestly they sit in the center
and they're like they point where
everybody should go and they generally
will like mirror the running back and
like standing and what is the size of a
middle linebacker like uh this guy
usually was either size they're like the
biggest the the best combination of
speed and size so like a 250 really fast
guy 250 what six yeah
so what is my single thing so how did
you get that job
[Laughter]
was he paid for it that was a great
buildup
i'm trying to understand i don't know
football right but it's in high school i
feel like you have to take what you have
no i i was in elementary school in high
school i was tiny no i was
the the reason why i was running back in
linebacker and you running back two yeah
but then like my
junior year the coach said that he
wanted me and this other guy only to
focus on making our primary job be
linebacker that being said i could see
the field great like i had great like
anticipation of where the play was going
to go so i'd always get to the right
spots at the right times and i just get
most of the time i get run over but like
i just slow the like i'd help slow the
guy down slow down so you had a lot of
focus yeah like i was able to
he's trying to show nick that he cannot
be replaced
his presence was missed
don't get down about those numbers
if we would name that one chappelle's
quit we would have hit six digits again
yeah oh you're so proud of the numbers
you sent us all of your texts well
there's good numbers last one yeah cause
i named it cat quits
[Laughter]
i was down for the clickbait this guy is
gonna be called addressing the
controversy
go to
slash dark magicmind.com
code for 20 off and uh quit
procrastinating i bet if i would have
took this yesterday i would have made it
to the show
[Music]
cat took it that's why mixing up the
matcha with the honey make it hit
okay i'm feeling great what's got me
feeling good what's helping me
in the back
you know we do have another video we
have to play because we play it every
time you come here okay oh my god
our boy yeah
man oh that's [ __ ] love dude you know
and then after that we have one more we
have to play oh dang we got videos
galore last week we played the uh shank
smith diss and i [ __ ] forgot to play
the video with it oh
yeah these guys haven't even seen it
there's a video yeah it's a lyric video
yeah it's funny it's funny but and any
excuse to listen
to my mac
it's called
what is it called
it's called my mac my neck my [ __ ] and
my crack
i don't your mess up pop it up
i'll just send it to your phone
is that okay yeah you have that video
saved like
right in your favorites
like on a radio definitely chappelle
gets down you pull that up watch that
video and suddenly he's like you know
what y'all on the bench
let's zoom in
we need to zoom him in next week yeah
i just got to figure out what it is
again we've set it on here we have to go
look back in an episode
we'll just find an episode where we have
browse on and we'll find it
[Music]
come on man start over we can't do this
we gotta do justice dude we gotta turn
this into a real song and remix it oh
yeah let's do it okay
[Music]
forehead starts to glisten so let me get
started
[Music]
[Music]
gosh that's so hard oh my god
i think his name is eric sanchez is what
his name is
i'll find his gram because i screenshot
it it hits every single time it hits
every time it's always good like what
gets better than that nothing natural
like when you think of jay-z you need to
think of eric sanchez yeah what do you
think of snoop dogg when you think of
freaking nas kenji
kendrick lamar neck and neck you need to
put eric sanchez in the [ __ ] lion
because if you don't then you're just
kind of like not a hip-hop fanatic man
yeah yeah aficionado i want to remix
that and make it a real song that it
never gets old yeah we should give him a
chance to get like [ __ ]
okay make that track let's do it
because the the gem towel part bro like
whip you out like a gym towel
what
i mean he says those words together but
like when you could just cut it out like
a chip
towel
that's the title
to like
glisten glisten
oh yeah
foreign frustration oh i can see the
cover right now without glistening
yeah yeah oh yeah glsen sounds like a
cover band for beyonce
that was glitter yeah that was glitter
but it is feminine glisten glistening
frustration is this a music video glitch
in frustration
that's a now that's a metal band
listening glistening frustration the
glistening
oh yeah it does yeah that's a gay porn
you're right guys so this is a tank oh
schnapp it's jake smith
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
i love how they keep
[Music]
you ever see this now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love how this picture keeps popping up
and it just keeps coming up the center
funny it's so funny the way it comes out
too
we should just have that in the middle
of our episode
who did that did you do that yeah who
did this that was peter that was peter
peter
that is awesome what's peter's last name
uh v-a-t-t-a yeah dude he's super
talented it's longer than that oh that's
the thing
i don't know yeah yeah he never gets he
never gets mentioned shout out peter
shout out
i mentioned him all the time
sorry these are the same no no no no no
no no no no no no no no yeah yeah dude
chris walked into that recording session
like eminem like he was just in the
background just pacing back and forth i
was like should we write it like do you
want me to write with you and stuff he's
like oh just give me a minute give me a
minute and he just freestyled all that
like he was coming off the top
i bet he had a bunch in there too though
like
he just kept going like he he crushed it
it was it was great
i feel like he can go head to head with
little dicky's career if you're just
like
because they're in the same exact lane
i mean lil dicky is is like a savant but
i i i think chris is really good too i
think
he's three styles on sway are like some
of the best youtubers dude
well dickie's amazing those freestyles
are amazing it's so you know who also
has the best some of my favorites
riffraff
oh my god
the greatest the greatest you've seen
them george yes and they're really
[ __ ] the holy one iconic one but i
know what you're thinking of was it one
of the sway yeah
and i was like
wait they don't have knees
like a month later just think about it
like wait a penguin ain't got no need
and that's a beauty in it it just
lingers and then a month later
is it really freestyling though i don't
want to be a hater no it is yeah this
one is actually
like legitimately freestyling
yeah you seem like he's
comes off the top
like little dickies are written but this
is the freaking
they'll throw a word
the
i got more knowledge than both your
parents combined i graduated
i graduated in 1991
uh i might pop trunk on your sister i
could eat fried rice and bacon
everybody
get a chinese
this past week i didn't really i didn't
know about riff raff at all no i'm not
i'm not super familiar because yeah from
g's to jens i didn't want that you
didn't know about that
all those videos
i did not watch
one yeah
i didn't watch any of those so i miss
riff raff but like as i started working
for theo he was the number one requested
requested guest like of course
constantly uh and it finally happened
and it was one of the best episodes
yeah one of the best episodes ever yeah
and just clean them both together
together
it was so good i felt like my brain
exploded
together and they get excited like when
someone would say like some crazy improv
lie like the other one's like
oh yeah
that's so good yeah he was on that jeez
the gents but he only was on one episode
yeah the first he got eliminated the
first but he made structure but he made
some success
one episode
and that was all he needed and then he
got mtv tatted on his neck
because he hated vh1 i don't know oh
wait what's the mtv yeah he has the mtv
test right now was that an mtv show no
it was a vh1 show but veg1 i think is
owned
i've been a fan ever since and he writes
his songs are actually like really
really dope i hate that i said actually
sorry riff raff i didn't mean to say
that his his the songs are legit uh but
i think actually he's like oh he's like
he's not serious but he
he he's he's talented yeah that's what
matters
i think
i think that guy is genuinely him
i don't think it's an act at all or
anything of that nature i love riffraff
i hope it's not an app i feel like
takashi 69 is inspired by him
oh takashi six knight could never touch
wrestling he could i know i'm saying
he's inspired by them
has anybody watched the takashi
documentaries i've heard they're really
uh there's one where he [ __ ] does the
pedigree to a girl for one of his
videos you know what the pedigree is
yeah
it was it was it was out of the blue and
i was like why did the documentary show
this
and it just like it just shows them like
rabbits like yeah yeah yeah then the
kids are down he's like
then he just goes back into his rap and
we were like what the [ __ ]
i think that a lot that alone tells you
everything you need to know about that
oh yeah yeah she should be show
chappal pedigree christian just so
everybody knows what we're talking about
mm-hmm
this
sorry i was looking at uh no you could
type it in type in go to youtube
basically
pedigree
when you bend someone over you put their
head in your crotch and then you like
slam them to the floor but you also get
butterfly hooks rather than a power bomb
type of body lock no no
or if they show takashi doing it yeah
that'd be yeah i want to see a refresh
yeah yeah i'd rather see let's see if
they show
i knew what you meant or i knew what the
rest of the pedigree was right away but
i was like no way in this context is
that what we're talking about
no they didn't show it oh there it is
when we were watching the dock
we were so confused we were like
what did i have to do with amy
it just cuts to that i don't i don't
think that's
i'm not confused at all if you have that
much money and these women will just do
whatever you want you have no this would
do wrong
that was on the come up
oh okay like that yeah he's not he's not
colorful right there yeah no tattoos on
his face
but i bet he was doing everything i
powerbomb i like how she just agrees to
it stunners she's getting paid yeah
it sounds like the bed breaks in it
because she [ __ ] jumps with them look
it yeah you gotta sell it
wow
yeah
that's what came up with it for those
that i don't know that's triple h
the king of kings the game
brows sent me this video that he wanted
me to play so i'm just going to play
this really quick oh yeah well that was
just chris in the studio recording that
part great segway
oh wait i might even have the wrong one
but whatever
yeah you're sick but you're not fat
the accent was killing me
so that's how you do it just line by
line don't call yourself
that was kind of the wrong vid but
whatever but yeah it was funny i always
get a huge kick out of taking comedy
seriously like you're like he's doing
this silly voice but then like very
serious notes about it like oh yeah
it's it's a weird dynamic it is weird
yeah yeah like dissecting it no yeah i
never thought about that until you just
said that like when we're like writing
stuff we write it in the tone of like
yeah
i feel like i'm [ __ ] mozart you know
what i mean when i'm writing my [ __ ] and
then i just say the goofiest [ __ ] ever
yeah do one of the funniest things it's
important to step away and remember like
what you do silly one of the funniest
things uh one of my jokes was posted
um from a set i did on don't tell comedy
and it was a joke i do about my adoptive
parents
and how you know they the punishment the
punishment one right
and i just you know i'm like if you
counted me basically it's me saying like
if you counted me i'ma beat your ass
you know like it's initially what i'm
saying
obviously a joke yes
someone goes
i don't know where the comment is you
ain't got to show it i don't want to
hear it
i don't like watching myself could we
insert it right right here so yeah it's
right there and impossible someone
someone goes
oh my god this is so disrespectful this
family gave you another chance at
and the fact that you would do this
you're a toxic person
yes
people took that [ __ ] damn i don't
care if you gave me a new chance at life
you can't count at me
right good answer good answer good
answer so
have you ever told your adopted folks i
pulled that line where you're not my
real dad you're not my real mom oh no
i've never done that i mean i got cause
obviously i know oh you were a teenager
yeah i was a teenager yeah i was like
yeah that'd be funny you know my dad
was like he's like yeah
you should know that
no uh but it's just it's just funny
people
just like oh my god you sound like a
toxic person no i'm not saying that's
every comment but you always get that
that was the funniest one
that they thought
then you gotta find it and just let them
get roasted oh yeah i should i should
have
damn it chess
i don't think you could have done that
what'd you say i don't think you could
have done that because if don't tell a
comedy poster you can't control that oh
yeah usually
yeah if they if you post it you can
control it yeah they collapsed it yeah
so damn it but you can't still
it's a funny clip
and it's funny thing to say that yeah i
beat your ass no it's great it's funny
because i mean my adopted father's a
little guy and it's an obvious joke
some people i guess just don't take it
as a joke he uh
literally like short king a little oh
yeah he little he's like five six oh
he's like a certified short kid
oh that's adorable but he's so funny
he's right here
that's your dad i am his dad
hold on that's why there's so much pent
up
so the photo i'm about to see daddy's
christian is a photo of me
my biological father in my adopted
father
oh wow oh
would this have had been at a show
during one of your arizona dates yeah
when i was just in arizona got it yep
did you get a christian yeah
did it come through
it did
mr mitchell is his real name mr mitchell
oh it is funny to say that huh
mr mitchell mr mitchell i love that did
you used to call him mr mitchell or by
his first name i ain't call nobody
nobody daddy ever
[Music]
gangster
yeah the one in the polo
look at my dad in his weed hat it's so
funny because that watch my doctor
father's just such a christian man yeah
like very religious like reads the bible
every morning at starbucks and drinks
his green tea
now you gotta throwing up games now he's
throwing a [ __ ] he's doing the peace
sign asian style
he's like that's all yeah
yeah he don't know what's going on no
it's cool though yeah both of them there
yeah it was it was cool doing a show
back home
uh
this time around because it was actual
fans in the audience and not family
members which like sucks
yeah it sucks so bad when or where does
your uh real dad live
in phoenix uh
i think an awesome chappelle's world
would be both of them honestly
dude
it'd be awesome they're not ready i
don't think my adopted father would he
don't want to be in the in the light
like in that world yeah he's just like
dude
being part of what you yeah he is they
are but i i don't think he would he'd
probably be like no because that's your
thing
just just a great thought that's a good
thing that's wrong
you know it's funny you know what's
funny about that joke
is that like i do
a very dad white
voice
but
that is how he sounds
yeah and people think i'm like you're
like oh you're just making fun of white
people to get all white people sound
like that go no no no mr mitchell sounds
like you heard him talk
that's exactly how he sounds
just
very
dad joke that is that's him yeah that's
why i wrote that joke
can i hear the voice i don't know the
clip just real quick you know my voice
is not really oh come on
you know i'm a singer
and you know
oh the one where like my dad's trying to
get a fight with someone like hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
come here man
and nick's like fine all right
transition yeah that's exactly what it
sounds like and it's so adorable to me
so i could never growing up i never felt
like vietnamese men were threatening at
all even though i grew up around a lot
of like asian thugs because of that
voice because all i think is like hey
man [ __ ] you [ __ ] your motto okay
come over here to my house i beat your
ass like that that's what i heard and i
think it's so cute that's cool
i think joe coy does a joke boy does a
great like vietnamese accent yeah yeah
type of jokoy
youtube he does a great
vietnamese guy doing white guy accent
his uncle something no no no yeah
filipino that's a great bit i love that
works with my uncle i feel like that's
where he gets the vietnamese accent from
and probably joe's uncles yes absolutely
oh oh the vietnamese one is one too yeah
he does the vietnamese one he says that
vietnamese people sound like uh
like they did a bunch of cocaine and
then start talking
it's hilarious
oh i think he might do it in that this
different asians i think
[Applause]
i think the first one might be better
quality yeah
the way you can tell ages apart
it's by their accent and only if they
have accents
out of all the asians koreans are the
easiest
person talks they sound like they've
been smoking weed all day
what
jim
listen
until he nails it
god damn it he's on me
he's on point he's on point
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so freaking funny
[Music]
[Music]
yo the way he [ __ ] looks
oh here he goes
[Music]
really yes absolutely we are the
smallest but they're dangerous as [ __ ]
but we're vicious yes we're like
chihuahuas
they will fight anybody yep amen they
will those [ __ ] will fight they don't
give a [ __ ] i don't care how strong you
are
they will fight you
they will run up to you and say [ __ ]
[Music]
i had one run up to me
i'm telling you it's accurate
it's exactly what it sounds like
[Music]
dude he's so good he's so [ __ ] he's
one of my top favorites yeah i'm the
nicest guy nicest guy he's the best
remember he says he loves all of us
every time he's oh yeah shows he shows
up
yeah he hugs everybody he feels like an
asian uncle to me because every time he
comes he comes bearing gifts like he has
rejected he has a merchandise
for you he would literally shake my hand
with a hundred in it like that was the
most uncle really what produced his
podcast at corolla i didn't
i wasn't working for him he worked for
podcast one yeah that's where i met him
oh and he's been he's the [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah he's the [ __ ] you give you a
hundred and a hand just every once in a
while yeah he'd just be like
like on his way out like just awesome is
this [ __ ] guy you're the most baller
[ __ ] ever he's got better
such a nice sweet guy dude and he's
blowing like
he
easter sunday is a like he wrote and is
directing a steve or stephen
spielberg directed from the movies yes
spielberg spielberg saw his special was
like oh i want to work with this dude oh
really yeah i think it was that special
or the one before one of his specials he
saw spielberg saw it and it was like yo
and the first one he just gave away to
netflix he's like just put it on i'll
pay for all of it just take it all of it
and he blew up afterwards he's so
awesome dude yeah amazing he put you on
that's it
he let me open it yeah i told him i was
like bad ass is this yeah cause i uh
what's crazy about that
is when i first the first time i ever
saw him live
he said something to me because i was
like oh i was i said i'm gonna stand up
comedian or whatever he saw he said uh
you know what maybe one day you'll open
for me and it [ __ ] happened and he's
legit he said it yeah but that but like
i didn't know him like that and i wasn't
anything i i was only a few months into
stand up i think when he had said that
so
when that when that happened and then
he hits me almost like yo
you know come open for me in phoenix and
i was like oh my god that's [ __ ]
insane that is incredible man insane
great great [ __ ] dude shout out to
you amazing dude yeah yeah we all love
him
who are your favorite people who you've
opened for
that i've opened for or yeah yeah
british shop yeah
you're not in the building it's fine
oh man
bill burr there you go that was a that
was legendary because that was a crazy
one
because he saw me working valet
and i helped him with his bag he didn't
even know you do comedy
no we had talk no we
i can't we were talking about it i told
him i was a comedian but we mainly
talked uh about the celtics or whatever
because the celtics were playing the
suns and you know he was doing around
the shows
and so he was one that was just [ __ ]
like he was just like
let's see how funny you are and i was
like
that could have gone so bad oh it could
have gone so bad but then he let me he
let me finish the weekend with him it
was him and paul versi
uh that that weekend yeah so it was him
and paul versi
uh trying to think of who else
was really fun i've opened for so many
[ __ ] people it's
[ __ ] hard to remember that's like the
type of answer i was looking for
billboard yeah yeah
that was yeah that's huge that literally
was yeah
what year was that
2017. oh wow it was a while ago and i
would think i was a year back in the
stand up how nervous were you going up
to open for bilber at that like
experience level i mean it was insane
cause i was like man i'm just a valet at
the time i was only doing you know local
shows around the the comedy scene but i
was doing like bar shows or whatever but
because of that
that show it had put me on the map in
phoenix yeah and i started getting all
this love love from the clubs and then
um it was brian
brian and some other people that were
like yo you should move to
l.a
and then here i am i told this i talked
about this on uh oh yeah which goes out
uh
two uh on below the line james from
sheriff yeah ceo of magic mind do that
that that was podcast below the line
yeah i did his podcast that i produced
oh you saw it okay nick not yet the one
that i produced we already
no i haven't seen it yet i just got the
footage but uh no it was dope
he's a great guy yeah he's the man great
questions
i was like man you make me really yeah
he's so focused he's drinking yeah yeah
very true that's why
the actual magic mine dialed in he was
dialed in you asked me questions that
i'm like man i've never thought about
that until you just asked that
and and he's like he's a wealth of
knowledge in like silicon valley and
like investing but he's like past and
like bored with that because like he's
he's started companies and sold him he's
got money magic mine's kind of his pet
project but his whole thing is like he
spends like eight hours a week doing
magic mine and it's like
two million in sales last year now he's
like all philosophical like he's about
to go spend a month in india at an
ashram
oh wow like yeah he he said something
that i don't think i've ever heard
someone really
say to me he was like man you're just so
emotionally connected with yourself i
was like yeah
i was like i never thought of it like
but he just like
it was just it was cool yeah nice guy i
mean so yeah look out for that below the
line podcast yeah tall man tall guy yeah
he's a tall guy taller than
you dude
brendan yeah
whoa how tall is he oh he's tall he's i
uh he he's probably he's probably six
four but he's skinny that's [ __ ] tall
six
he was a basketball player in texas
yeah we had we had texas roots he and i
hey so do i yeah oh yeah you do yeah
don't forget we should have him come in
the studio for an episode yeah he's just
got like super tight schedule yeah he's
like an actual businessman
in a dad
yeah and a dad like
and the way he like blocks out his time
i feel bad asking for his uh his time
but i don't know he also
had a great time like he really enjoyed
it i i was like oh we only need 15
minutes and
he spent a half hour with each one of us
he's promoting magic mind that shows
focus and awesome
memory he knew everything about every
single one of us and he asked questions
about all of us right like what the [ __ ]
that was pretty cool is that because of
the magic mind yeah i guess so
it makes you reading people's minds and
[ __ ] no just knowing about i don't know
about that no oh no i think that's a
different side of reading people
schizophrenia i wish i wish it was magic
muscle
would you want to know what was the
question brian asked us if there's one
thing you would want to do what would it
be like something that we can't do oh
yeah you said fly and he laughed at you
in your face yeah he was like what would
you want to vlog i was like why'd you
ask the question
i would love to fly what would you do
yours would be fly
when i dream i have like lucid dreams so
the first thing i do is like launch up
in the air do i do the same thing yeah
right [ __ ] yeah dude it's the best
feeling how do you do that i heard you
can train yourself to do it yeah so you
can i don't know what that exactly is so
lucid dreaming means you know you're in
a dream
you know you're actually going to dream
and it kind of hits you after a while
like for me if i walk in i'm walking
around i try to turn on the lights to
the bathroom yeah it doesn't turn on and
i'm like
i'll go another bathroom doesn't turn on
yeah i'm like
hold on i must be in a dream because
this is not real yeah so then i started
like taking control of that dream and
i'll be like you know what i do
i want to [ __ ] fly
flying
and like coasting around yeah it's so
amazing and you do a lot of other stuff
too which i'm not going to explain but
yeah or that's just a trip
yeah what do you think wait so what
would you want to do
fly would actually obviously it's so
amazing when you fly uh but one thing i
researched it like a while ago or
started to like
meaning i googled it but the first step
i saw was like if you ever wake up from
a dream first thing you do write
everything down you can remember yes and
it starts making you like you kind of
know what you're seeing when you're in a
dream so then all of a sudden you
realize you're in it it's so hard to
remember dreams so yeah write down
immediately nba
i played in the nba that was that's your
wish not to fly your wish well i i've
always said if i'm talking about
superpower i've always said if i could
fly i wouldn't tell anyone and i would
just use it to play in the nba
oh so i could just do this i just i just
be [ __ ] yeah duncan boards like a
little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just
to go i'd obviously go on like night
cruises and [ __ ] and enjoy it but i mean
what
so you essentially want to be icarus
i'm gonna fly too close to gargoyles
that was such a good cartoon oh my god
that's what i knew saturday morning
cartoons were over when gargoyles came
on you know like garland
i watched gargoyles
the main gargoyle was so hot to me as a
kid well there you go yeah yeah i was
like this guy comes on it's off it's too
dark and brooding that's why i loved it
it was kind of a dark show there was
nothing like about it that made you like
it wasn't approachable you know what i
mean
it's just a [ __ ] what channel was
that on was that right around uh
disney tunes was it upn i thought that
was wb or oh www or whatever wouldn't it
yeah i think it was wb
yep that main one oh my god okay hot it
was kind of it was kind of a random show
when you look at it you're like
it doesn't make sense did you guys watch
uh courage the cowardly dog oh that was
scariest [ __ ]
that show still creeps me out it
literally makes me feel like i'm
tripping on acid every time i wash it
yeah it's like horrifying it's a cartoon
based around this dog who wants to
protect its owner muriel and she has a
husband that's like this mean old man
and there are things that are coming
around trying to like kidnap her oh is
this like a oh it's so trippy no it's
not it's not it's about domestic abuse i
know right
i figured out a show an animal
show with a girl that had superpowers oh
uh i saw someone say in the comments
they can't remember what it was someone
powerpuff girls no it's called out of
this world out of this world
someone else said uh the one i saw
actually i was like oh
i'm pissed if i didn't know it was it
was secret world of alex mack no no it
was a show out of this world is there
anybody famous that was in it
famous in my heart yeah i've never even
heard of it which is
out of this world you never heard a tv
show
[Music]
maybe if i saw it i might it might
trigger something
oh something you have to clear up yeah
lots of controversy after the uh
are you smarter than a sixth grader yeah
we had one question
what are the least amount of
current u.s coins that can make 99 cents
did we do we all get no we we all
answered it correctly based on how jeff
foxworthy originally asked the question
yeah because when he said curry he meant
in like current circulation yeah so not
including the 50 cent piece which is not
currently in circuit circulation
but that would be eight if you counted
that which is still legal tender but i
blame jeff oxford okay it was all
cleared up that's tricky circulation
that's tricky yeah and that concludes
the first ever errors and omissions on
cats after dark aerosol yeah
first friends
oh yeah we were looking up out of this
world but then we kind of no that was
just for me oh cool
that's up for the group are you doing
this for y'all
oh also you did jk news recently how was
that you did
oh yeah aj came in it was way too high
huh i just got really high there oh yeah
but i didn't know that and i was excited
about it i loved it i loved their i
loved
it i love their format
they're such great guys too and i love
the format of like having
one news story reacting to it like a
tangent it's uh jk go to youtube there
we go
yeah there you go
those guys are great they did the very
first like
youtube vietnamese uncle sketch
the uncle sam they were infamous for
that
uncle same which was the like back in
the day like early i'd say
like
2008-2007 the uh one of the ceos of jk
made a sketch called uncle same
where he is basically making fun of
vietnamese men that he grew up with and
he does this vietnamese accent and it's
hilarious
that's what like made them blow up oh
okay okay they're like o.g youtubers
what's cool is um
that format like they bring up a lot of
topics but they're so
loose about the topics yeah because i
was like yo i was like i don't pay
attention to pop culture much
i don't have any true hot takes on
anything except like if i see it i don't
know i'll go
okay but they were like no don't worry
about that like yeah you're fine you
could just be loose with it i was like
okay cool so it was it was actually a
lot of fun
you know yeah they're not trying to
[ __ ] break [ __ ] down they're just
that's what i thought i was like i'm
like
their slogan was uh teaching you new
things in a bad way
ooh i like it damn i think that's what
their slogan yeah they have a good
format they i mean their structure is
amazing
they're all good dudes they have so much
fun with it and they it's it's the least
amount of pressure
ever yeah it was it was dope
joe was the one who helped me out with
all of my like
only fan stuff as i was coming out
because i did their show for the first
time uh just as i was kind of getting in
the swing of doing only fans and i
didn't know what to do one like
how am i gonna do my taxes this year
like what do i do with this money where
i'm not like blowing it but i don't feel
like i want to like hoard it in a bank
account either joe is so money smart he
just set me on like the path to like be
financially safe yeah and he just did it
he's a smart dude he's smarter
but he
yes but he's so [ __ ] smart is that
who you hit me this is no his cousin is
my cpa who uh
right
and he was on this past weekend
way long time really it was one of my
four maybe my fourth guest episode with
it it was this past weekend 144. so
that's him
he's so funny he's hilarious he was
cracking me he's like a rich homeless
guy yes
he's just hilarious so funny yeah like
the richer he gets he says he wants to
live a more minimalistic life and he got
to the point where he was just like
couch surfing voluntarily for years just
so he could go and travel i respect that
i follow him too and he does a lot of
the camping and yeah he's really into
camping he loves the outdoors
he made a video recently when crypto
crashed saying i lost a million dollars
again
it's hilarious oh it's just had a heart
attack it had a hard crash yes very hard
crash
suicides went up so quickly within that
24 hours no way
but it comes back yeah every time it's
starting to bounce back a little bit
every time
that just happens i'm like i'm so glad
but like like a crash is like not
uh i don't know crypto too well so i'm
trying to understand it uh but it but
it's but things are gonna come back some
of them are some of them aren't they
were like some coins
based on i don't know i don't understand
the technology but there were like some
there's one example because i know uh a
friend of a friend
he made a bunch of money on luna yeah
that's the one joe put a bunch of money
into and that's the one that yeah and it
was like considered a stable coin
somehow used something that was tied to
the us dollar so it was never supposed
to fluctuate too much but one little
component like crashed and
that thing's never coming back like it's
it's like a penny now and
it i don't know people
if you put in like really early all of a
sudden it blew up and they're like oh my
god i have a million dollars and now
they're like oh i lost a million dollars
but they
invested 60 bucks to begin with i don't
know but people started living off of
that like million dollar
profit and that's where it starts to
really hurt people because let's say
like you put in the 60 you made a
million and you don't pull out that
million and have it in your bank account
you're still kind of playing with it
keeping it there so it can go higher
that's the hope but you fall out of
control out of control behind the scenes
without the million dollars in your
account so it's a move to when it like
rises
take some out leave a little bit in that
would be that would be very i mean
anything with investing you're supposed
to diversify and have your money like
all these different yeah bets and [ __ ]
most people who hit rich and they're
like oh i have a million dollars they
put everything they had in crypto
and i don't
know
joe's fine joe
joe has a diversified portfolio i'm sure
oh yeah he also has like businesses
independent
look like you uh
crypto i've never done crypto if i had
money
a year ago
i didn't have any cash
do i look like i do crypto
well i barely understand instagram
i don't [ __ ] with crypto i saw a post
recently saying that crypto is like
astrology for men and i can't that is
that's hilarious it's hilarious
that's hilarious
uh
in you rising
yes
what is it predominantly men that do it
yeah i would say
crypto bros
no
yeah that's the thing
no
yeah you do [ __ ]
i don't i want to i just don't know how
to do it
it seems like i hear about it
more than anything
talk to my dad he'll get you set up i
think it's become because it like
it just has a bigger rise and fall so
like when it rises really fast
everybody's like oh
like all the people have crypto they're
super loud and like everybody else is
like oh damn what is this crypto thing
okay but then it crashes and everybody's
like see it was a fraud it's a ponzi
scheme blah blah blah stocks are like
the same also doing very drastically but
it's not like
200 percent down to whatever it's like
oh a 30 it lost to its value they should
play the song lightning crashes every
time it crashes
none of you guys know lightning crashes
every time it crashes
can you sing it no one knows lightning
lightning crashes if you sing a little
bit of it i might know what artists
should we live for
they're called
yeah we just haven't played it on that
category no one knows the song lightning
crash who's it
by live sport
song
what
run
lightning crashes bro i know we can't
play it but play a snippet of lightning
you look like a disappointed teacher
like we turned into quiz and we all
failed yeah
what
yeah you didn't like us
oh i know this song everyone knows the
song yeah
they're called the title
we just know the song yeah from here
yeah
they don't even say lightning in it do
they do they
[Music]
the angel love is right
i remember this music video too let's
get demonetized i don't care
[Laughter]
the first thing he says is like
it doesn't even say lightning
[ __ ] first lyrics
yeah and then never again and it's not
in the chorus is it
uh
oh no wait uh
[Music]
i don't know any other words
clearly
uh
uh no no he does not say it
hey courses i can feel it
he says it a decent amount of times
thunder chasing
that's the part everybody knows and he
doesn't say it once
he says it only one
i think
twice i think there's a performance of
him performing at like woodstock or
something
annihilates
you know who else would perform that
woodstock
uh
on the way
ice age
yes send me on my way
i love them you know
you ever seen that one uh you ever seen
the past
with john leguizamo
no harry spears
no no you don't see the past i saw the
fighters
came on he was [ __ ] sweating
one of the bloodiest
shits i've ever seen he was angry and
sad that guy was just
i wasn't i thought he was just very
curious if he's a buddy or something
he's super talented i don't know oh you
just recommended a movie i was thought
you were breathing no no no no uh you
said john leguizamo you said the movie
the best
i think you would like that movie i
don't know about anybody else in this
room but you have that kind of humor is
he like a house guest and he stays too
long no
uh i can't remember it's been a minute
but it's just a funny [ __ ] movie
it's it's like a classic
comedy
it's really good i'll check it out i
trust you and then they like try to kill
them
it's a yeah it's a funny movie
pass control
no just pass i know you're trying to
kill you see joe's apartment
uh i remember the commercials for at
imtv with all the roaches with all the
roaches and [ __ ]
you don't see that yeah i saw that have
you heard of joe's apartment
no no um
i think we keep going random until we
agree on one okay
so how do we unless anybody has a
category they like to do how do we how
do we pick this so we're not like how
about we have one of them pick
one oh yeah that's good that's a good
idea just a category of trivia yeah
category jules and georgie and jersey
lexi what you got topics
what is what do we do we already did a
friend's once we can't do that um
it's a underused site that has a million
trivia questions you're so good at this
i know right are they sponsors
i love trivia they said animals animals
i love it
animals by eyes close up
by skeleton try to do one where it
doesn't have you know those i have like
killed which one family matters oh yeah
you did so good in the family matters
and then we realized none of us
you know what else you killed the show
last night max peaceful did oh yeah
yes you did so did you my friend you
guys that was great everyone was there
we didn't know what to expect we were
just like yo let's just [ __ ] go
no yeah you looked and told me on stage
too right yeah yeah
and you had a mosh pit people actually
came out to
was sick oh we were laughing we were
like yeah people [ __ ] with us you know
who's sick your bass player that was
doing the scream vocals oh yeah yeah
that was fire
yeah more stories from the show
i thought it'd be an hour well yeah if
you were there yeah
yeah that's why we haven't talked about
it nick
yeah he's like i want to hear about it
it's kind of painful though you know
it's kind of painful to talk about it
you are you gotta you got someone to
tear uh tear a hamstring
yes really yeah oh yeah yeah he went by
yeah that's how hard we go they were
going hard for you guys it's a war on
stage for us man yeah that's what it is
do you recommend people stretch the
ground
i tried to get in the crowd a little bit
but the the mic table was like too short
oh yeah did you see me i went down in
there and i was like and then it
immediately got well
i tried to get a little circle going
wait so this animal's easy let's go
wait what okay now we we just have to
yell out animals we see on the screen
and that's what
that was the one i saw
um donkey
kappybo
flamingo
ostrich
definitely hamster zebra koala
i don't
toucan a sea dragon
buffalo
should we go like row by row and guess
horse fish
okay yeah sea urchin elk what the [ __ ]
is that thing koala
definitely
llama
uh-huh uh spikey ball llama puffer fish
puffer fish yes oh that was spikey's
ball
uh two cannons someone said urchin
didn't they
i did bro i don't know how to spell it
you are rc-h maybe you see the horseshoe
no
wait i'm not a horseshoe i mean
he was looking at it you're so confident
the male 1 you don't see the horseshoe
no you didn't see the horseshoe you're
so mad at me do you see the horseshoe
wait what do you guys two minutes and 45
seconds people get it together
i don't know what that is
the cute little australian man i can
barely spell in english i can't spell in
korean oh [ __ ] it's not korean it's
australian or something like that dude
fox isn't coming up iguana is that a
wolf
wolf oh coyote coyote
oh did you get the beaver are those
clams right there i don't know they said
beaver fever that might be clam or
mussels mussels tribe muscles
m-u-s-s-e-o
aardvark
dude what
there we go
aard vark hey what's that bird flamingo
[ __ ]
typing birds so mad about this
buffalo
wow what is this why isn't it coming up
emu oh it's armadillo
um
hey that birds are emu there we go
where emo emu yeah there you go second
fastest bird
what is this i can't even see it so what
is that i can see that right that's a
cocoa
cucumber
so it wasn't any fox it wasn't a coyote
look what is it is that a reindeer
puffer fish is that a puffer fish yeah
oh caribou jackal caribou nice try
jackal
son of a jack
nice there we go puffer fish puffer fish
is that a puffer it's not a puffer oh
damn i can't see uh uh you guys just
kind of reindeer was right look at that
urchin
urchin
jellyfish jellyfish jellyfish
you say urgent urchin
stingray
where
the stone looking thing is that not
one word possibly what what the [ __ ] is
the big bowl of container
oh that's a bird
onyx onyx
on yx
that reminds me a wedding i don't even
know what the [ __ ] a quail looks like i
know
that's
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
should
let's do another quiz i know what we're
doing now bro let's get away from
animals next week
can we no we're definitely not doing
that let's do
their food do a food
do a food can you need no how about two
is like two thousands hip hop thing
okay we got this this is early two
thousands hip-hop can you zoom in try
typing yeah we can't see yeah there you
go okay
oh i got this like
i kind of
so we do have to do this we can't just
yell him out he has to be clicking on
the one let's okay i got a line for line
and then if we don't know anything
that's right
okay so first one kanye
pop bottles is birdbath yep bow wow
little bow wow get you out of a little
bow while featuring
uh uh
let's turn it up i don't know turn it up
ryden nelly nelly this has to be hip-hop
nelly right turn it up nope not now i
don't know uh i don't know it's play
reaction get like me as young jock
get like anywhere young jock then it's
the one the one underwriting
right under the yellow bar under the
yellow bar play
oh there's two songs from each people i
didn't realize this just jlc jlc yeah
all right try
y-u-n-g no i think it's jlck maybe
no it's glc from whatever you'll see
uh last night and tell me that's diddy
i thought that was ass yeah um go hard
that's dj
fabulous yeah
fabulous
hurricane chris hurricane chris yeah
where hey baby
shite
what uh just like me blame it jamie foxx
uh uh
jim jones jim jones jim jones or um yeah
one more time one more drink
i'm redeeming myself from that uh nelly
isn't this isn't this gluta chris too
move yep [ __ ] get out try it i don't
think that's ludicrous
like that's gonna be someone else
no baby do you want it like this
like this
yeah
applies
wow no not applies
oh
ah something just went out soulja why
isn't that working uh
wait what
you l before the j yeah sold yeah
obviously um bartender's t-pain t-pain
ti ti
wetter is uh lil wayne maybe he hasn't
won but we already have one so i don't
think it's that the one is 50 cent 50.
the next one is next one yeah next one
is trace songs after that
who's what
[Music]
hotel service is that pitbull hotel room
service
i know you want something creepy i know
right yeah this is a very great is our
kelly lolli
who sees that lolly pitbull
no this is early 2000s
she's not out yet so what we have three
that we don't have
four or four turn it is turn it up chris
brown
no i think he turn up the music who's
get like me
chris i thought it was junk jock how's
it going because he has a song get like
me
u n g y u n g j
bruce banner oh yeah david
low
[Applause]
i'm embarrassed i think of dirt my
clothes
and we ready chicken wing are the last
two
oh and then the stay fly and molly molly
oh yeah and safely
oh
those i feel it's like it's a group
who sings that
we balling boys yeah i
they did the miami hurricanes theme song
i feel like little john should be in
this too somewhere oh is it uh trick
daddy what happened oh
okay kanye we weren't going to get them
anyways to be fair play quiz and then
see results or whatever
god damn it we'd have to restart huh no
if you if you just end it there's this
oh the results we failed them all let's
see what what happened how do you end it
i don't know follow your heart
so we only missed two though oh give up
right underneath the time
we did pretty good though
that was a great sportal session
wait is that is that we stay far
[Applause]
what songs
so fun fact about that song okay
fun fact about three six okay
you know what three six is right what
the satan's six
yeah
they're talking about lucifer says
you're my king
you're my father
it's called memphis memphis like devil
circles or something like that's a
conspiracy yes jesus christ guys shout
out memphis rap chappelle so someone
sing the card someone's seen the chorus
is that how you know that no
one of my friends told me uh sing the
chorus someone
don't point at me
yeah that was so gospel right there i
love it
that's what they're saying back there
yeah really
yeah
okay watch play i mean if you wanna play
civic if you're for the first time has
gone down oh yeah going down
yeah you're talking about going down
mm-hmm
what's down hell exactly
yeah this is so funny
you just gotta hear the chorus
they
caught me
no
jump hey they make hits yeah 36 mafia
makes hit this sounds hard
go no go back go ahead go back
go
back
[Music]
what are you saying about chappelle and
dark
hey
cats after dark baby
that's hard what is it what is it what
is it
abg thing
rap devil is he like this i think it's
that it's your beard is weird
texas longhorns
they call me the juicy you know i'm
stuck right in the car was a bummer in
the trunk so he got some heads and then
what breaking down uh told him he didn't
know it was a problem
[Music]
uh oh london whoa okay june 2nd hello
that's it a few weeks yeah isn't it
in like two weeks
two weeks i'll be in london man did that
just come together like that yeah that's
like last minute what came up well i
told my well the concert the concert
came first so going to see liam
gallagher the next day
but i told my reps i was like hey i'll
do a show out there so they found a club
about 150 seaters which i thought was
fair i was like yeah i was like don't
give me something like give me a [ __ ]
theater or something you know not that
they would but you know something within
reason that i feel like you know i feel
like we have a lot of fans over there
and
i think it'll be a good time so june 2nd
i'll be at the 100 club in london and
then uh june 24th and 25th
yes
rhode island i want to see what you
rhode island kids are like uh at the
comedy connection and then some stuff
later in the fall so
that's where i'll be all right come see
me man
i swear i'm a funny guy you've been
talking to jack sharks
no i need a message sure jack shaw will
be there he said he wanted to go yeah
patty
come on paddy the body come on ollie
he's in
liverpool yeah yeah i don't know the
stretch
i think you can get anywhere in three oh
yeah cause it's like yeah it's super
small yeah well patty you're on the
guest list jack sure you're on the guest
list
it's tommy fury
meatball or meatball molly which one
which way does it go molly's
meatball ball
anthony joshua you're on the guest list
yeah tommy fury tommy farrier
actually i can't guess unless you i need
to make money please buy my tickets
purchase the ticket
tommy fury you're out there i'm very
sorry
he's doing fine he'll pay for a ticket
uh who else is dope out there paul
mccartney
well he's probably
here that's there
or something
uh who else is out the spice girls give
me something else spice girl
spice girls victoria beckham victoria
beckham
scary spice mm-hmm
ginger spice
baby slime cow i think he's here oh he's
here yeah loser uh
who else is out there
give me ufc fighters darren till there
oh darren till what's up
guess what also liverpool guest list
uh who else is out there bisping yeah
but he's back here he's in there
he's in irvine now yeah never mind all
right bisping staying irvine
um
who else is the famous fighter out there
i care about is jack shore jack shaw
jack shaw's the man jack shaw's guest
list for sure
number one he would not be buying
attacks
you know he's fighting next right
i didn't know if i saw him post the post
i don't know if it's a real fight so
yeah
yeah he announced thomas should be ricky
simoneau yeah i think he was trying i
think he's trying to make it okay so i
saw like two different posts uh so yeah
if you see it from a third party because
he said like here's fan art i made i
haven't seen any yeah so i saw from g's
fx who makes awesome graphics so he
posted it and then yeah i guess jack
sure did it so i don't know no so i'm
saying it's not official but that'd be a
dope fight
a little it makes me nervous yeah
exactly a little little much well
that'll be a dope fight but you got it
there's no one yeah because he's [ __ ]
killing it yeah
i believe in my boy yeah
that looks so bad
don't accept bottom
yeah
yeah come through if you're in rota if
you listen to this in your island come
through see chappelle uh he's not that
funny um so
no but for real come through come see
him come see me uh follow me on
instagram see paolo six uh and go show
love to this new podcast i'm helping out
on uh it's called you already know
it has uh keenan thompson and his boy
tani morales on it so awesome go give it
love
quick thing i had to say
it is pretty funny when
seeing uh fans geek out over seeing
christian yeah fans geek out yeah they
they got overseas
it's kind of fun
i don't know why
you're like
do they call you christian or meatball
or it's a mix oh it's a mix that's
awesome though yeah they have it last
night at the show of course dude
[Laughter]
i want to dedicate this song
lot of sorrow yeah it was a sad song he
had like a picture of you in the
background while the song was playing
pictures of you together
yeah
people have to carry me off stage too
yeah i was trying to carry
he's coming i'm telling you he's coming
so basically show up show up next time
all right yeah yeah we'll do my bad
but i almost didn't show up today
because i didn't show up last night
yeah that's fair where are you gonna be
nick uh check out another podcast show
we've been uh joking well playing some
celebrity boxing my buddy dylan really
wants to fight uh
uh senator mitch mcconnell okay
so i i went ahead and made the first
steps that happened and i emailed the
senator's office mitch mcconnell and i
read my email on our latest episode of
another podcast show and uh
yeah i think i think we could make this
happen i'm trying to fight aaron carter
and
my buddy
yeah i feel like aaron carter is also
half of your size yeah
not in high school
i feel like he's a very skinny yeah he
said what he said
what he said
and my buddy pat wants to fight some
random person who was on the show below
deck
so it's star studded card star studies
yeah another podcast network another
podcast show damn he was that small um i
well we just did the show last night
trying to get another show going in the
future maybe run another one back in la
uh thick boy albums out now give it a
listen it's on all streaming platforms
dude eric griffin's trying to get a
check for that for what yeah
[Applause]
everybody's like for the whoa i didn't
know this is like a real thing
that was pretty good erica was pretty
good that was pretty good he was also
supposed to come to the show last night
but didn't make it
yeah i'll give him some writing credits
on it
oh just i just want to say thank you so
much for everyone that came out to this
show
i feel like
seriously no
i've been saying like it means the world
to me if everyone comes out and so many
people came out you guys are incredible
some people didn't come out but
it was incredible the show we thought
okay
more people showed up than we thought so
it was amazing and they were awesome so
yeah nice to meet everyone you hear that
next show come out again enjoy
when's the next show do you guys have
one planned or no we have one in texas
right well we're doing ohio again in the
summer we're doing a festival in texas
we're starting to get some rolling so
we'll post dates um but i want to do
another one either in la or orange
county yeah soon hopefully and just yeah
pack it out
the back
oh subscribe to go george go my new
youtube i got yes two vlogs out i saw
the vlogs they're amazing dude really
great job thank you everybody
follows the man's journey subscribe to
george's uh
out check out george's block
shout out trevor yosuda oh yeah shout
out to trevor dude trevor he helped us
out so much on this he's on the cia the
the whole shows and just rehearsing
everything he's the
best yeah he's awesome
thanks jules you can find me on
instagram at teen all my links are in my
bio onlyfans.comteen
i'm doing vlogs again so that's cool if
you just want to watch a bunch of videos
of like me recording stevie and butters
there you go
why not oh yeah hell yeah well signing
out thank you guys for coming today yeah
thank you
thank you for coming nick yeah nick
thank you for coming
[Music]
[Music]
you